i've been using apple watches since the
series zero and i've upgraded basically
every year but this year i'm returning
mine in this honest long-term review
i'll not only tell you exactly why
but also why the series 6 is by far the
best apple watch yet
and why if you can afford it you should
absolutely buy one over the se
or a discounted series 5. the apple
watch has been shockingly successful and
i see them
everywhere when i ask people about them
they always say that they love their
apple watch
the series 3 is still being sold and
bought like crazy so how can apple get
people to spend more money on a series 6
instead of one of the less expensive
ones basically it's incremental new
features and little exclusives that
force people to spend more
and by the looks of it it's working this
year we have a few new colors which are
really cool
mine is the product red and we have the
new blood oxygen sensor and the always
on altimeter
of course we still have the ecg support
and probably the biggest one
is the always on display if you need
those sensors for health
reasons the series 6 is absolutely worth
it but i feel like most people don't and
they buy the top model for just one or
two reasons
after using the s6 for a while now i
think that most people
should buy one not because of the few
incremental improvements
like the maybe brighter display but for
the real world differences the apple
didn't advertise the series 6 has killer
battery life way better than before and
i don't know why apple is not making a
big deal about it
on top of that after two generations we
have an
actually new processor that not only
allows for this battery life improvement
but super smooth perfect performance now
most people don't care about an
occasional stutter with a cheaper watch
but as i was brainstorming and going
over comments and
contemplating returning mine something
became
really clear to me most people make
buying decisions
based on today and not how they will use
the product a few years from now
and with apple watches people are
keeping them much
longer than their phones i'm seeing tons
of people keeping them for three
four and even five years we start
looking at it from that
perspective the extra 50 to 100 dollars
more from a
discounted series 5 or even 120 dollars
more over an
se starts to make a lot more sense
forget the extra sensors or the cooler
colors
or even the always on display the series
6 is going to be a supported and smooth
running watch
5 years from now and that's something
that i can't say for my series 5
or the se which already have some
occasional slowdowns
on top of that we have some features
that almost nobody is talking about
and that apple didn't really mention
that make it a nicer device
first off that u1 chip that only the s6
has
we still know very little about it but
based on leaks it will allow the apple
watch to not only be very accurately
found and
maybe find other devices but support for
authentication
and for accurate secure unlocking right
now you can unlock your mac with your
watch
but the u1 will be much more secure
allowing you to unlock your house or
even your car
quicker and way more securely every new
apple device is now getting this u1 chip
so having this in your watch means that
you'll be good
even years from now this might seem
minor but notifications are so much
nicer and more pronounced than with the
older apple watches
it's still silent but their vibrations
feel twice as strong
and i've definitely appreciated that
especially when using it as a silent
alarm to wake up in the morning the
brighter display in the always-on mode
when it is dimmed and when you're
outside can be nice as well
i'm saying it this way so you won't get
confused now when apple said the display
can be two and a half times brighter
many people didn't understand
completely what they meant even we
didn't when we first tested it the
display brightness is identical to the
series 5 in most scenarios
my biggest complaint with the series 5
is how much that screen dims and it's
always on mode
and i wish apple would let us choose to
keep it brighter
but sacrifice battery life at the same
time i do understand why they don't
because with the s5
i end most of my days with about 10
percent of battery life remaining
now despite the larger battery in the
series 6 apple still doesn't let you
customize it
and in normal lighting it's exactly the
same now let's talk about the most
impressive part that apple won't even
admit to
and that's the battery life it's still
rated at 18 hours like my series 5 was
but there is a world of a difference
instead of ending with 10
at the end of the night i now get 35 to
40 percent
and other people have commented that at
the end of the day they have 50
remaining now let me tell you why having
that extra 30 to 40
of battery life can make a world of a
difference to many of you
and how some of you guys could get
double the battery life compared to an
se
even though i end my day with 10 battery
other than having the display at its
brightest settings
i'm not somebody that pushes my apple
watch very hard
i do exercise but it's usually not long
and it's usually indoors
the times that i have for example when
hiking my apple watch ends up dying
before the end of the day
and a few times before i was even done
with my workout
if i don't take my charger i'm without
notifications or tracking for the rest
of the day
with the series 6 this will be much less
of an issue
and not only that it charges 20 faster
as well
another benefit is for sleep tracking
which just came out with watch os 7.
with my series 5 i have to place it on a
charger about an
hour before bed and then once again in
the morning or else it will die a few
hours into the night
with the series 6 you could charge it
once in the evening
or maybe instead in the morning when you
get up and you're ready for the day
and that's with the always on display
mode enabled now if you're somebody
considering between buying an se that
doesn't have always on
or spending more money on a series 6 if
you turn off the power draining always
on display mode on the s6
your battery life will skyrocket i've
seen people get over two days of use
and that's with sleep tracking and with
workouts which no other apple watch can
do
now that is thanks to the faster more
power efficient processor
the larger battery and the lack of 3d
touch hardware
if you don't need fantastic battery life
keep in mind that as time goes on
the battery will degrade and i saw one
guy who upgraded to a series 6
just because his 2 year old series 4's
battery no longer lasts throughout the
day
now with the 6 the extra battery life
will really come in handy
3 years from now now let's get into the
disappointments and why
even though the series 6 is so nice why
i'm returning it
i already told you guys about the
always-on display that still dims way
too much for my liking
and even though the battery life is so
good they still don't allow you to set
it brighter to me this was the biggest
excitement with the series 6
and if it was two and a half times
brighter in normal lighting conditions
and that's where i use my watch
ninety percent of time i would still be
keeping it
right now i still have to raise my wrist
to clearly see my complications
the second disappointment is that the
oxygen sensor is super
sensitive half the time it doesn't end
up working so i have to redo it
and typically my levels are fine anyways
so i'm not ever
using it now i do hope that this could
be improvement software for those that
do need it consistently
the last thing is pretty minor but it's
that the product red sport band
doesn't actually match the watch at all
and some people were actually commenting
and thinking that apple sent me the
wrong
watch band and they didn't this is the
right one last year i solely upgraded
for the always on display
and this year even though the upgrade is
much more substantial
for my use case charging every night it
works fine
and i'm no longer using a sleep tracking
feature if i use that or if i was a lot
more active outdoors
or if i knew that i was going to keep
the watch for three to five years and
that extra battery life would be really
helpful
then it would be worth upgrading but
because of this channel i'm almost
certain i'm gonna be upgrading next year
so i'm not too worried about battery
degradation and even though i
love the better vibrations that alone
isn't worth spending more money
with all of that said if you're
considering buying a series 6
and you can afford the extra price over
an se or a discounted series 5
i would absolutely advise you to buy the
series six
it's an excellent watch and you're gonna
be happy with it for many
many years make sure to check out the
links in the description below for
discounted apple watches
and also the merch shelf where you guys
can find super comfy premium shirts like
this one
hoodies and even masks which support our
efforts here on youtube if you want to
see my direct detailed comparison
against the series 5
or vadim's excellent review of the apple
watch se with apple's master plan
those videos are right over there and go
ahead and click above to subscribe if
you guys want to see
more videos like this one this been max
and i will see you
in the next video